et puis vous le rencontrez à cannes en
et là est ce que vous êtes vraiment
agréablement surpris est-ce que c'est
celui auquel vous vous attendiez bah oui
ça on dit souvent il faut pas rencontrer
ses idoles on prend trop au risque
d'être déçu mais
là cette photo par exemple c'est lui qui
me dit mais bien en photo avec les
points comme ça alors il ya deux choses
bon d'abord sur cette photo je suis le
mec le plus heureux du monde à ce moment
là c'est un moment incroyable
et je finis en larmes évidemment
mais
non ce qui me fait souffrir à ce moment
là c'est que
je parle quasiment pas anglais
ma dyslexie m'a empêché sa
est la première fois de ma vie où je me
rends compte que c'est vraiment une
punition c'est que je rencontre mon
idole qu'il est adorable avec moi je
suis incapable de lui parler
donc
le le défi de ma vie maintenant c'est
que
j'attaque des cours intensifs d'anglais
et j'espère que je vais pouvoir tourner
avec lui un jour et lui parler est ce
que le fait de comprendre et d'apprendre
que vous êtes hpi ça